I'm in Tromso in Norway that is the
Tromso bridge and the beautiful Arctic
church there now I've been following my
videos from here for the last couple of
days you might have noticed something a
bit weird
every time under artificial light and
let's be honest that's most of the time
because while it does get light in the
middle of the day here we're in the
Arctic Circle it's winter the Sun
doesn't get above the horizon mind you
when it does get light this place is
beautiful anyway you might have seen a
bit of a weird effect if I take a
slow-motion video of that streetlamp in
the ground under it you'll see what I
mean there's this kind of weird strobing
rolling effect going on and the reason
for that is something you might not know
the difference between the European and
American power grids see the European
power grid runs at 50 Hertz 50 cycles a
second that means the alternating
current in the wires switches direction
a hundred times a second 50 cycles back
and forth back and forth and that means
that all these lights that you can see
pretty much dim imperceptibly
100 times a second not enough that you
can see it with the naked eye but the
camera will pick it up now okay that's
not a major problem if your camera runs
at the same rate as the lights the
lights run at 50 Hertz British
television runs at 50 Hertz but
unfortunately I'm using an iPhone which
is designed in the US for the American
power grid the American power grid chose
to run at 60 Hertz 60 cycles a second so
American TV runs at 60 or 30 frames a
second so the camera is recording at 30
frames a second the light is pulsing at
50 Hertz those two are out of sync and
so sometimes you get light sometimes you
get dark but why the rolling effect well
for that we have to understand the
rolling shutter in a camera or in any
modern camera old film cameras don't do
this obsolete us expose a shot every
time a frame goes by but no no not this
this camera and all modern cameras run a
line at a time
scrolling down the screen which means
that it can take a fraction of a second
difference for it to go from the top of
the frame to the bottom and the result
is this rolling effect some of those
lights are recorded when the light is
fully on and some of those lines are
recorded when the light is dip and
that's the reason that's the reason you
have this kind of weird artificial
rolling light
problem when you're filming with an
American device in Europe cause the easy
way to fix it would be for Apple just
have a 25 frames a second option but
that would be far far too difficult for
and that is something you might not have
known